- It's really good to
see something you know,
positive happen for Tom Brady.
I'd like to tell you a love story
it's about president Donald
Trump, and his television.
Now the billionaire real estate developer,
turned reality TV star,
turned president of the United States
and all that really happened.
Has had his fair share of ups
and downs in his seven
plus decades on earth.
He's been married three times,
he's declared bankruptcy six times
and so on and so forth.
Now only one thing has
been by Trump's side
all of those years, good old television!
And specifically cable television,
now Trump has always been both
acutely aware of the power
of TV and absolutely and
completely addicted to it.
A look back at his Twitter
feed easily reveals
this obsession, quote
"#noratings Lawrence will soon
"be off tv bad ratings he
has a face made for radio."
Trump treated way back in 2011
about Lawrence O'Donnell's MSNBC show.
Side bar, it's 2019 and the O'Donnell show
remains on the air,
that's eight years later.
Quote "Rosie O'Donnell has failed again."
Trump tweeted in 2012,
"her ratings were abysmal
"and Oprah canceled her on Friday Night.
"When will media
executives learn that Rosie
"just hasn't got it?"
And then there's this one from 2013
on Dallas Mavericks owner Mark Cuban.
Quote "@mcuban has less TV persona than
"any other person I can think of.
"He's an arrogant, crude, dope
"who met some very stupid people.
On and on, on and on it goes,
and the story it tells is
that TV has long been the way
Donald Trump interacts with the world.
The advent of Twitter made
this fact all the more obvious
over the past decade or so,
but it's hard to believe
that Trump hasn't always seen himself
in a sort of give and take conversation
with his television over the years.
Now given that it's utterly predictable
that as he ran for
president he relied deeply
on TV for his views
and his what's the word
I'm looking for, expertise?
This exchange from a
Trump appearance in 2015
on Meet the Press tells you
all you need to know about that.
- Who do you talk to for
military advice right now?
- Well I watch the shows,
I mean I really see
a lot of great, you know
when you watch your show
and all of the other shows
and you have the generals.
- You have the generals, right,
and Trump's TV watching habits,
even during media interviews
during the 2016 race would often drive
the candidate to distraction.
In an August 2016 interview
with the Washington Post,
Trump on at least two
occasions glanced at the TV
and offered commentary
like, "lot of energy.
"We got a lot of energy."
and "That statement's gotten a lot of play
"I love that statement we wrote."
Distracting right?
Since he arrived in the White House,
ehh nothing has changed.
Wrote the New York Times of
Trump in December 2017 quote,
"People close to him estimate
that Mr. Trump spends
"at least four hours a
day, and sometimes as much
"as twice that, in front of a television,
"sometimes with the volume muted,
"marinating in the
no-holds-barred wars of cable news
"and eager to fire back." end quote.
In the parlance of the Trump White House
the president's TV watching
and Tweeting about what he sees
on TV fits into the category
known as executive time,
and according to schedules
for the past three months
obtained by Axios there's been a whole lot
of executive time happening these days.
Since the 2018 election
roughly 60%, six zero percent
of Trump's work schedule
has been given over
to executive time.
That works out to almost
300 hours of executive time
as compared to approximately
77 hours in which
Trump has spent in
meetings focused on quote
"Policy planning, legislative strategy,
"and video recordings."
one thing that has changed
since Trump was elected,
is that he's less willing
now to acknowledge
just how much TV he actually watches.
Quote "Believe it or not,
even when I'm in Washington
"or New York, I do not
watch much television."
Trump told reporters aboard
Air Force One in 2017.
"People that don't know me,
"they like to say I watch television
"people with fake sources."
You know fake reporters, fake sources.
"But I don't get to watch much television.
"Primarily because of documents.
"I'm reading documents.
"A lot."
Ah yes the old can't watch
TV because I'm reading
documents a lot excuse, if
I've heard that one once,
well I've heard that one once.
Here's the problem for Trump,
despite his claims that he
doesn't have time to watch TV
he makes very clear on
an almost weekly basis
how much tele he actually takes in.
In defending one time press
secretary Sean Spicer,
Trump reportedly told aids quote
"That guy gets great ratings.
"Everyone tunes in."
In explaining why he decided
to pardon conservative writer
and pundit Dinesh D'Souza
last year Trump said this.
Quote "I didn't know him.
"I read the papers.
"I see him on television,"
and in January alone Trump
Tweeted positive things
that were said about him, or
backed up his policy positions
on Fox and Friends at least eight times.
It's all very simple, cable
TV is the lens through which
Trump see and understands himself,
the country, and the world.
Which may not be the best way
for a president to see things
and that is the point.
We make new point episodes twice a week,
check out new ones every
Tuesday and Thursday.